the history of call of duty is littered
with loved and
hated perks in this video we're gonna
let the hate
flow through you as we recall the perks
so bad that their removal became actual
selling points for future call of duty
games if you love talking about shooters
like we do
make sure to subscribe to the channel
and give us the old thumbs up let's get
to it
the juggernaut perk first appearing in
call of duty 4 modern warfare was the
answer to one very simple question
how would players feel if we nerfed
their bullets in real time and then
showed them it was happening
turns out they did not like that
juggernaut decreased the damage players
took by around 25
which gave a large advantage in 1v1
fights and pretty much forced every
other player to use it
or equip a counter perk such as stopping
power and if you're gonna put that in
the game you've kind of wasted your time
making the other perks
to be fair it wasn't all bad juggernog a
very similar concept made its way to
zombies where it was a perfect fit and
became essential to surviving the whole
supernatural thing
[Music]
next up if you've been playing much
modern warfare or cold war
you've probably seen some serious knife
warriors running around the map at full
sprint trying to prove that blades are
still relevant in the age of gunpowder
but it used to be
way way worse commando from modern
warfare 2 straight up teleported players
over 4 meters to deliver a one-hit kill
it was so bad in fact that it ended up
as a selling point for modern warfare 3
that it had been removed definitely no
definitely definitely no commando perk
if that's not bad enough there was even
a pro version of this perk that got rid
of fall damage and could be exploited on
maps with large drops
the underbarrel grenade launcher bear
with me is in virtually every modern
call of duty game but it was pretty well
established early on in call of duty 4
to be the new weapon of choice which is
why it was a bit head-scratching that
the awesome power of the noob tube
was enhanced in the sequel modern
warfare 2 which increased explosive
damage by a whopping 40
with the danger close perk not only that
but danger close could be paired with
one man army which allowed players to
constantly resupply grenades by
switching class mid match
at least if you died to a noob tube you
knew it wasn't your fault
and i will strike down upon thee with
great
vengeance and furious anger oh man are
we talking about grenade spam
revenge from the afterlife was never
cheaper or took less skill than
equipping the martyrdom perk from call
of duty 4. with martyrdom
players dropped a grenade when they died
it wasn't that deadly at range
but very infuriating for aggressive
players especially indoors
[Music]
players despise losing progress towards
a high tier kill streak from someone
with this perk equipped
despite being generally disliked
martyrdom appeared in eight different
games
one of those being a ds game just go
with it get moving
and take out anything in your path
taking heavy fire
we're here to move captain this perk
could even be enhanced with sonic boom
that made it deadlier over a longer
range
next keeping with the cheap stuff you
can do after losing category is a perk
that gave players a free drop shot
last stand allowed players to fall to
the ground with their pistol out and
attempt
instant revenge it meant that every
player you faced with last and equipped
had to be taken out twice
it was even worse in world at war in
black ops where variants of the perks
showed the players position to their
team and allowed them to be revived
lasting wasn't just hated by players
devs hated it so much
they used the f word when referring to
it and we don't mean fun
no last stand
[ __ ] you last dad then there's stopping
power stopping power increased bullet
damage by
40 it's the kind of perk that pretty
much guarantees no other tier 2 perk
will be picked
why even bother why would players want
to get consistently beat if they don't
equip
magically more powerful bullets on the
receiving end it was just as frustrating
to know you may not have been beaten by
good movement
or better aiming just someone who went
to a menu and equipped stopping power
oh boy what are your most hated perks
from call of duty and do any of them
still exist today let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to watch
our video where a weapon expert breaks
down guns from all kinds of games
including call of duty modern warfare
thanks for watching
[Music]